we start with the carnage in Chicago
chaos in Portland violent crime surging
in nearly every major city in America
Democratic mayor's Democratic governors
they have failed in their most basic
duty and that is the most basic
responsibility to maintain law and order
they have failed and people are dying
and being shot as a result they have
failed to keep their neighborhoods safe
they have failed to prevent violent
crime as a result men women and children
are dying our fellow Americans are dying
these mayor's are literally twiddling
their thumbs and playing politics
Philadelphia's top prosecutor is now
vowing to arrest any federal law
enforcement agents that are sent to the
city but president Trump is taking
action today in a major press conference
he announced the expansion of what's
called operation legend that's a federal
program it started in Kansas City was
named after a four year old boy who was
killed by gunfire while asleep in his
own bed well they'll now say more than a
hundred federal officers to Chicago 35
to Albuquerque were there having a
problem in order to help take violent
criminals off the streets
mayors aren't doing it the governors
aren't doing it listen to the president
the citizens of Chicago are citizens of
America and they have the same right as
every other American to live in safety
dignity and peace no mother should ever
have to cradle her dead child in her
arms simply because politicians refuse
to do what is necessary to secure their
neighborhood and to secure their city
every American no matter their income
their race or their zip code should be
able to walk their city streets free
from violence and free from fear for
this reason today I am announcing that
the Department of Justice will
immediately surge federal law
enforcement to the city of Chicago the
FBI ATF DEA US Marshal Service and
Homeland Security will together be
sending hundreds of skilled law
enforcement officers to Chicago to help
drive down violent crime
safety security is the foundation for
our great American dream every child
every neighborhood every city deserves
to be safe you can't climb the ladder of
opportunity without security and safety
this president committed to making
serious progress all over the country
let's go back to his conference earlier
today my vision for America's cities
could not be more different from the
lawlessness being pushed by the extreme
radical left while others want to defund
defame and abolish the police I want to
support and honor our great police we
want to build factories in Baltimore not
Beijing we want to make our products in
Chicago not Shanghai we want the
American dream for American children and
I will fight to deliver that dream every
ounce every single ounce of my strength
I will be fighting but opportunity
cannot thrive whether as violence
prosperity cannot flourish whether it's
bloodshed and security cannot exist
where there are violent criminals who
are able to maim and murder with
impunity that is what operation legend
is all about operation legend is a
beginning its greatly needed in all of
these cities now a hundred agents they
cannot save and protect these cities
they can't they can protect well federal
property they can help in investigations
they can get to underlying groups that
are fomenting this violence but a lesson
until these reckless irresponsible
democratic mayors and governors do their
job and or allow the help they're being
offered they are allowing innocent
people to die that is all on them New
York Chicago Philly Baltimore you name
the city Seattle Portland it's all on
them especially true in Chicago
shootings are up 47 percent over last
year homicides up by a whopping 51
percent seventy shot last weekend 63 the
weekend before even children are dying
every single week the violence reaches
catastrophic levels by the way last
night we reported on the
perfect mass shooting in the south side
of Chicago 15 people seriously wounded
outside of a funeral home wood appears
to be a gun related incident at least 60
shell cases were covered from the scene
caught on camera by a nearby
surveillance system take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Mayr lightweight isn't doin anything to
protect her city moments later to
visibly shaken witnesses compared it to
a war zone as the president's been
calling this and applauded the
president's plan please help us please
send in help well the mayor and governor
won't let him do that take a look we
wish it would stop and we're glad the
federal troops are here in Chicago
because the violence is literally just
his burden versus depend Ora as this
devastating scene unfolding sadly a
typical night Chicago's mayor Lori
Lightfoot is a lightweight in terms of
protecting people busy on Twitter what
was she doing bashing two presidents
from tweeting under no circumstances
will I allow Donald Trump's troops to
come to Chicago and terrorize our
residents she clearly hates the
president more than she cares about
innocent men women and children in her
city Rahm Ted Fisher man yo he didn't do
anything either Barack Obama's president
barely mentioned Chicago thousands shot
thousands died Biden did nothing at the
point one move these liberal mayors and
governors when do we hold them
accountable for not protecting innocent
people hundreds of people shot every
week in Chicago and a lot of these
cities six small children have been
killed in July alone last night a three
year old little girl was shot in the
head but the mayor is worried about
troops terrorizing her city really now
what has she done to stop the violence
what has she done to save lives
Lightfoot who's a lightweight on
protecting citizens seems more worried
about optics and politics and the men
women and children that she is supposed
to protect and serve it's a national
disgrace she's not the only Democrat
putting politics before human life in
Portland we see the same thing Democrats
there pop they're apoplectic
federal agents would try to protect
federal buildings from being burned to
the ground that is their right and their
job Portland's mayor calling the federal
officers they're literally the officers
not the anarchist not the people
involved in the violence call the
officers unamerican Oregon's stupid
governor floating an insane conspiracy
theory that they were abducting people
Pelosi get this comparing agents law
enforcement agents that put their lives
on the line to protect and serve storm
troopers congressman Clyburn the
leadership in the Democratic Party
referring to them as Nazi Gestapo
meanwhile corrupt and confused Joe Biden
he's not set a single positive word
about law enforcement the 99% since
running for president he accused federal
agents of quote brutally attacking
peaceful protesters now we also have
heard him say that police have become
the enemy and he supports the defund
effort or as he calls it we will
reallocate resources he likes that work
better let's be clear a Turkish vandals
have been riding for nearly two straight
months in downtown Portland they
firebombed a federal courthouse twice
they possibly permanently blinded
federal officers with lasers dozens of
buildings have been vandalized lit
ablaze businesses they're shut down
people don't feel safe these are not
peaceful protests Joe and here's just a
small example of what law enforcement is
facing take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
where do you see all the video with ami
Horowitz who's on the ground in Portland
as we speak there have been more than 50
straight days of violent demonstrations
in the city's downtown district remember
according to Biden federal law
enforcement officials who are the real
enemy here see what's happening Biden
doesn't have a plan to stop violence
make America's city safer to protect
innocent people so he just trashed his
Donald Trump now he's even deploying one
of the old Democratic Party favorite
tactics he's now playing the race card I
pointed it out I've done this history so
many times every two years every four
years like clockwork Republicans they
are racist sexist misogynistic
homophobic xenophobic Islamophobic they
want dirty gear in water
they want Grandma and Grandpa to eat dog
food cat food before Paul Ryan or a
Republican or Trump look-alike throws
granny over a cliff in a wheelchair and
today Biden accusing Trump the president
of being the first racist president in
history get ready for a Hannity history
real lesson in a second we have racist
and they've existed they've tried to get
elected president he's the first one
that has and the way he pits people
against one another is all designed to
divide the country put y'all back in
Chains all right now it's time for a
Hannity history lesson forget the fact
that Democrats have accused every
Republican of being racist we've gone
over since 1998 radio ad in Missouri the
2000 James Byrd ad Al Gore Republicans
don't even want to count you in the
census they'll put you all back and
change let's go over the facts here's
Joe Biden's history it was Donald Trump
not Joe and not Barack who passed
criminal justice reform and prison
reform it was Donald Trump it wasn't Joe
it wasn't Barack who signed off on
police reform it was Donald Trump also
doing Opportunity Zones targeting mostly
minority neighborhoods to help well
build the economies in in neighborhoods
that have been left behind by Joe and
Barack it was president Trump not Joe
not Barack who ushered in record low
after record low after record low
unemployment for African Americans
spanic Americans Asian Americans women
in the workplace youth unemployment
african-american youth unemployment Joe
and Barack they didn't do any of that
matter of fact 13 million more Americans
food stamps 8 million more in poverty
lowest labor participation rate in Oh
since the 70s and a 51 year low in
homeownership rate in the worst recovery
since the 40s that's there 8 years of
failure and by the way three years in
President Trump has done more for
minorities in this country than Joe
Biden Nancy Pelosi and Chuckie Schumer
did in 125 years what's this you look at
employment you look at opportunities
owns and maybe most importantly owned
you look at criminal justice reform you
look at prison reform I've done things
that nobody else and I've said this and
I say it openly and not a lot of people
dispute it I've done more for black
Americans than anybody with the possible
exception of Abraham Lincoln nobody has
even been close the media mob they're
the biggest contributed to the Biden
campaign and all things radical extreme
democratic socialist they'll never tell
you that so you need to ask yourself a
question what was Biden doing during his
50 plus year career in the swamp for
african-americans are the minorities
here's where it gets interesting
I'll tell you Democratic friends we know
he was very close and spoke so highly of
the former Klansmen Robert KKK bird yep
former Klan leader Biden called bird the
Dean of the US Senate a close friend of
mine and a mentor that man filibustered
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 that well
Lyndon Johnson needed 80% of Republicans
in the House and Senate to get passed
because most Democrats they a lot of
Democrats were opposing it during a
speech Joe Biden in 1973 praised so the
Democrats said the two-party system in
the south was quote well good for the I
won't use the word around the same time
Biden was actively working with the
segregationists he didn't want
integration he opposed school busing
according to NBC News he led the charge
on an issue that kept black students
away from the classrooms of White's too
that's his record 77 Biden worried that
his children his children if integration
would grow up in a quote racial jungle
if integration is not done in an orderly
way whatever the hell that means
1993 referred to inner-city youth as
predators on our streets as he
co-authored the most aggressive crime
bill that ramped up prison sentences for
dozens of crimes specifically targeting
in the end minority Americans in 2006
telling a crowd oh you have to have a
slight Indian accent to work at a
7-eleven or Dunkin Donuts I'm not
kidding he said 2060 bragged his state
was a slave state 2007 he actually said
this about Barack Obama the first okay
the first mainstream African American
who's articulate and bright and clean
that story book man Wow last year he
said poor kids could be just as bright
as white kids and recently you ain't
black if you support Donald Trump Joe
decides that Joe Biden shouldn't throw
stones from that Glass House that the
mob and the media will never tell you
better yet he could just stop saying
racist things altogether Joe take a look
in the mirror when does anyone in the
mob and the media gonna ask him about
any of these things cuz that's the truth
that's the history and by the way
actually
who knows if Joe Biden could even form a
answer to any of these questions we're
gonna play is very latest struggles in a
moment it's not good